ok vamos a decir que esta vez el vector
de m
es igual al vector que tiene como
componentes xy y mira que esta vez no
nos dan las componentes numéricamente
nos están diciendo que el vector b tiene
como componentes x como my en su
componente x es la variable x y su
componente james es la variable y y
bueno también nos están diciendo que es
la magnitud de este vector de m es igual
a 8 y dice llena los espacios en blanco
y completa los siguientes enunciados el
vector w w con una flecha arriba de
hecho nos tendrán que decir que es
vector porque sabemos que es vector por
su flecha de acá arriba está de acuerdo
esta flecha representa un vector el
vector w
tiene como componentes menos 2 veces x
menos 2 veces y su componente x es menos
dos veces la componente x del vector de
su componente y es menos
dos veces la componente del vector b es
decir en lugar de aiete en m2 y en lugar
de x tiene menos 2x
bueno pues w esencialmente es lo mismo
que menos dos veces el vector b o el
escalar menos 2 que multiplica al vector
b y después dicen entonces la magnitud
de este vector w
a cuánto va a ser igual y bueno ojo ten
cuidado puedes estar tentado a decir que
está va a ser 8 x menos 2 pero recuerda
que la magnitud de un vector siempre es
positiva así que si tengo que la
magnitud del vector b es 8 y el vector w
es menos dos veces el vector b entonces
nos tomamos la multiplicación del valor
absoluto de al menos 2 por 8 no le
hacemos caso a este signo que tenemos
aquí porque recuerda que este signo de
que lo que hace es voltear nos el vector
y es justo lo que vamos a utilizar acá
abajo pero todavía no estamos hablando
de eso lo que queremos es la magnitud la
longitud de ese vector
ésta no puede ser negativa así que me
voy a tomar la multiplicación de 2 por 8
2 por 8 va a ser 16 de lujo ahora si
tengo una magnitud positiva y me voy a
fijar en qué es lo que pasa con este
vector z dice el vector z es el vector
menos un medio de x coma menos un medio
de james es decir menos un medio la
componente x del vector bm coma menos un
medio la componente i de este vector b o
podemos ver a este vector z como menos
un medio este vector de m o el escalar
menos un medio que multiplica a este
vector b y después dice entonces la
magnitud de este vector se está aquí no
es igual y exactamente igual que como
hicimos acá arriba podemos decir que
este vector b lo vamos a multiplicar por
menos un medio para cambiarle la
dirección y también la magnitud pero su
magnitud tiene que ser positiva por lo
tanto nos vamos a tomar la
multiplicación de un medio
no vamos a fijarnos en este signo o
dicho de otra manera vamos a multiplicar
el valor absoluto de menos un medio por
la magnitud del vector de que era 8 así
que 8 por un medio me va a dar 44 ya
tenemos una magnitud positiva y entonces
ya sabemos cuál es la magnitud de este
vector z muy bien después que nos dicen
es coincidir cada vector definido arriba
b&w o z con un vector que podría ser su
equivalente y aquí tengo tres vectores
lo primero en lo que puedes fijarte es
que estos dos vectores tienen la misma
dirección porque tienen un signo
negativo multiplicando al vector b
dicho de otra manera si el vector b va
hacia una dirección estos dos tienen que
ir en dirección contraria así que si te
das cuenta este y éste van en la misma
dirección y éste va en dirección
contraria eso quiere decir que este va a
ser mi vector
y bueno estos dos van en dirección
contraria ahora otra cosa que puedes ver
es que este vector w es el doble de
largo que el vector ver y tiene la
dirección contraria
entonces si nos fijamos en estos dos
este es el doble de largo parece ser el
doble de largo que este vector de m y
tiene la dirección contraria por lo
tanto este es una muy buena
representación del vector w y mi vector
z bueno mi vector z debe de ir en
dirección contraria y debe de tener la
mitad de la magnitud del vector de dicho
otra manera si nos fijamos en este de
aquí tiene la mitad parece ser que si es
la mitad de este vector de y además va
en dirección contraria tanto w como seta
van en dirección contraria a la
dirección debe muy bien creo que ahora
sí ya tenemos la respuesta y es momento
de comprobar nuestra respuesta hagamos
uno más que te parece este de aquí me
parece perfecto bueno pues tenemos un
problema parecido tenemos
un vector ve y tenemos que su magnitud
vale 10 perfecto ahora este vector w
lo estamos definiendo como tres quintos
del componente x coma tres quintos a
componentes james observa que es tres
quintos multiplicando a cada una de las
componentes de este vector de o bueno
podemos ver a este vector w como tres
quintos por el vector de o el escalar
tres quintos por este vector b así que
si la magnitud del vector de erati es
entonces la magnitud de este vector w
cuánto va a ser bueno pues va a ser diez
por tres quintos y diez por tres quintos
es lo mismo que seis estás de acuerdo 6
ahora el vector z es menos dos quintos
que multiplica a cada una de las
componentes de este vector o dicho de
otra manera el vector zeta es lo mismo
que menos dos quintos el vector de m
o el escalar menos dos quintos que
multiplica el vector ven pero recuerda
que este signo menos lo que hace es
cambiarle la dirección al vector dicho
de otra manera si queremos encontrar la
magnitud de este vector z habrá que
multiplicar dos quintos por 10 y no
fijarnos en el signo o tomar el valor
absoluto de menos dos quintos y
multiplicarlo por 10 y bueno 2 quintos
por 10 es lo mismo que cuatro de lujo
tenemos una magnitud positiva que es lo
que queríamos ahora vamos a ver que en
este caso el vector b es el más grande
por lo tanto si queremos coincidir
cada uno de estos vectores con su
equivalente el más grande va a ser b y
después podemos ver que el vector w
va en la misma dirección que el vector d
porque estamos multiplicando por el
escalar tres quintos que es positivo y
bueno tiene tres quintas partes la
magnitud del vector p así que parece
estar en el lugar correcto
va en la misma dirección y parece ser
tres quintas partes de este vector b
mientras que el vector z bueno pues el
vector se está va en sentido contrario
porque tenemos este signo negativo
tenemos al escalar menos dos quintos
multiplicando el vector b y su longitud
debe de ser dos quintas partes que la
longitud de b va en sentido contrario
perfecto y su longitud
en efecto parecen ser dos quintas partes
que la longitud de este vector b así que
si el vector de tenía una magnitud de 10
el vector w va a tener tres quintas
partes la magnitud de este vector ve que
va a ser 6 y el vector seta va a tener
dos quintas partes la magnitud de este
vector de que va a ser 4 suena que
estamos bien así que vamos a comprobar
nuestra respuesta de lujo estamos bien y
espero que esto te ayude a que tú puedas
entrar al sitio y resolver este tipo de
ejercicios